and did the idea for your movie the park
bench originally started to play oh it's
it's interesting that you asked that
because a lot of people say oh this
would make a great play but no it didn't
it was always a movie and there was the
way that I envisioned it really was
cinematic so um I I always really
thought even though with this dialogue
and you know and the one location I I
still always saw it as a very cinematic
film so no it was always a movie Nicole
for you as the lead did you almost
approach the role as if it was a play no
I didn't um I think a lot because um you
know every even though there are all
these separate conversations they're
also interconnected not just with each
other on how the relationship has has
come together and how it changes and
where it's gone in each one but also
each story they tell each memory that
they share everything brings up almost
like a different piece of then or a
different part of them and it's all just
so interconnected which is really a
testament to Ann and her writing um so I
didn't it was all even though it seems
like a lot of like kind of different
vignettes together it really is like
this kind of beautiful symphony of haha
of life so no I didn't I didn't approach
it that way to I've done many plays and
this is this was not this was very very
different yeah and you said previously
that in your films you like to have a
monologue or monologues that reveal
something about a character what does
this film the park bench reveal about
its writer director oh well I I think
that this I think this is a great
example of a film that reveals my my
take and my philosophy of
and gosh on on life I think I think one
thing I like for example in the way that
my characters relate to each other well
I think that's very real to me that
feels very real I think the characters
who talk around their feelings I don't
think they often talk at them or about
them I you know I think that's very
normal I think characters tease each
other I think characters joke around a
lot people people real people in life
that's what I meant to say so that's
what my so that's what they do so I
think this sort of i think this reveals
a lot about what I what I also my
thoughts on stories what I think about
stories I think stories are important
and I in this in this movie they're
important so that's what I wrote about
they are revealing and so that's that's
what they do they reveal in this film so
I i really think that this film that
actually is quite close to my own sort
of personal feelings about how we relate
to each other and how we move on in our
life you know together and and things
like that yeah and you've also mentioned
that your mom was librarian yes and that
she loved books yeah where did you
develop a love for filmmaking well I
think it's very related because I think
it's all storytelling right so I think
that you know my becoming a filmmaker is
not to the Apple not falling too far
from the tree to be honest yeah my
mother loved books and she loved sharing
them and she loved suggesting them for
people you know that was like the big
part of why she enjoyed her job and
that's I love it too for the same reason
I love revealing things and stories and
so filmmaking and I don't think it's too
too far removed actually do you to
remember the first film that you watched
and just felt like you came alive and
when you saw it you were like you know
what I was just meant to do this when
you felt that you were drawn Tom I feel
like I've always just known that I
wanted to do this I mean
dad has stories of me since I don't
before I remember but um for some reason
steel magnolias comes to my mother's
there right yeah oh that's interested
yeah it is interesting I've never talked
about before no one's ever asked that um
but um I guess that would have to for
some reason be my answered I'm not
totally sure why yet but if we need to
know why I can think about yeah yeah I
don't really I'm combatant it I totally
know what film it was that made me want
to be a filmmaker it's a hard day's
night and that weird that's what we're
going though right do you know why I
dunno why okay so my mother used to have
a film series at the library and they
would play these Truffaut films and
French New Wave and all these films and
I would you know really I beg her to let
me go even though a lot of films weren't
well I don't know maybe like the 400
blows or whatever you know maybe a
little over my my head but I always
really wanted to go so I love going but
I remember we would all sit in these
like library chairs you know heavy wood
chairs and they put up a screen this is
long time ago they put up a screen you
know and they'd play a 16-millimeter
film and I remember when they played a
hard day's night and the it was like a
real electric feeling in the i miss many
years after the Beatles had broken up
and you know it was like way way after
the Beatles but there was still that
that film is so thrilling you know if
you've ever seen it's worth going back
to watch it because if you can sit in a
big but there's something about it that
happens of its the day in the life of
the Beatles right and it's just it's
it's frenetic they're there the pace and
you feel what they feel which is you
know this sort of wild mobs outside and
you know it's sort of crazy and that's
how they filmed it Richard Lester as the
director it's just it's fantastic you
feel what they're going through and I
love
that I just thought it was thrilling you
know so I remember that being the
beginning of me being a cinema lover
right and this was in the East Coast on
yeah oh I was like ten okay yeah yeah
yeah it was a long time ago do we
remember why we like study Natasha I'm
the same age I was when I saw steel
magnolias yeah i would i would think I
don't even really know for some reason I
just felt like I felt all of Julia
Roberts emotions i really did I remember
her standing in the kitchen and the way
she looked at her mom and you know she
wasn't it wasn't okay for her to be
pregnant like she was you know all this
things and I remember just really like
wanting to stand up and say it to Sally
Field myself um so I mean I guess it's
also maybe you know just a little kudos
to Julie Roberts um but yeah and I you
know this is funny it also a lot was TV
too i mean when i was younger i would i
would watch whatever was on night court
and I would be like I want to be a
lawyer I want to be a doctor I want to
be this and my dad was like are you sure
you don't want to be those things on TV
cuz when you're a real lawyer no one's
watching you do your stuff and I was
like oh i mean i was way younger but I
was like oh no I want I want to do it
where everyone's watching me do it like
I was like I think I was like so that's
the first time I remember my dad being
like oh god should be an actress yeah
it's like I want to be a pilot I want to
be it so I think yeah speaking of which
um Nicole so many actors give up after a
short amount of time and I know we set
off camera that you've been doing plays
and things for for many years probably
around what ten when you yeah i mean i
started doing um kinda like a music
theatre kind of dance company when I was
like sex I guess okay tell me that it's
all a blur you've got that Italy yeah
and so what keeps you at it because so
many people do give up and sounds
from the east coast I did you know um
this will sound funny but number one
it's my only skill i am not athletic i
am not that smart no just kidding i am
super smart um I I can't even imagine
doing anything else I there's just
nothing else it's just kind of it is it
always has been it just is kind of my
life I just it's I mean not to get too
philosophical but you know like letters
to a young poet like if you must write I
don't it never mattered to me really I
never really wanted to be famous or I
know I don't know I just always wanted
to get to act and get to tell these
stories and I think that's one of the
reasons this is one of my favorite
projects is because it was just a
beautiful seamless story and I was just
felt so privileged to get to be the one
to tell it because it really came from
her heart I mean it's just obvious I
think that's why everyone connects to it
so much it's not controversial and it's
not like you know people you know
shocking or all this stuff it's just
this beautifully simply true story and I
and I loved getting to be the you know
the one to tell it and that's what I
look forward to is hopefully you never
know getting to tell another story like
and those are the kind of beautiful
moments that keep you going through all
the the all the other stuff that's not
so fun about being an actor it's project
like this one for sure well in keeping
with the literary theme of the film are
there any books that you can recommend
to others on the creative process maybe
they're not classics but their other
books that have really helped you
whether it's something like the war of
art or you know the artist way or some
I'm an artist way well kind of luck um I
think the mystic in the theater I love
letters so young poet I loved
The Alchemist which I read it I don't
know 12 years ago maybe I mean and now
it's become this huge you know book that
everyone's reading but I I've never ever
felt more like really connected and like
excited about my journey I read two
books that I really loved and one is in
the blink of an eye by walter murch and
it just really gets to the heart of what
filmmaking is even though it's about
editing but it's not it's really about
all filmmaking and the other is Sidney
Lumet and I'm blanking on the name of
the book but Sidney Lumet wrote this
wonderful book that breaks down
filmmaking into every every category of
you know pre-production through through
production and it's just you know it
just he's a storyteller right and so
everything is informed by how to tell
your story I that was a book that I
really remember being very helpful well
you both have such upbeat personalities
and I know an from listening to another
interview I found it fascinating about
how you sort of saw the world and you
were talking about I think your
daughter's school are there days that
you get discouraged though because you
just seem so uplifted by all of this I'm
sure that it's not always easy but how
do you view it how do you take on those
challenges uh well yeah I mean I I I
guess just in general you're it's true i
mean i just sort of try to keep
perspective and um and just push and
carry on i guess you know I you know
making films is hard being a filmmaker
is hard getting the opportunity to make
a movie is hard so I just sort of keep
going and I i I'm you know I in general
I think upbeat positive person yeah so
so uh you know I try not to wallow
basically that's a good one okay she's
she's so um I love this word and this is
so her she's so graceful she was on set
and we had
to shoot you know we shot for just a
week and we had so many setups and we
had to shoot and just in the daylight is
all natural light and it was so much at
stake every day and not only it's also
her story so not only is she directing
it but it's you know and I never ever
saw her not be like authentically
graceful like always concerned about how
we were doing how we were feeling about
the store like she never lost it ever
and we're both moms um that can be super
challenging and she's so inspirational
to me I mean she has this whole career
and life and a child and she had this
story in her heart that she wanted to
tell and I mean the time and the
commitment and everything it takes to do
that and the way she did it he's really
really inspirational to me and I would
think anyone who got to see you work and
do your thing so it I wonder if it goes
back to what you had said also to about
just like just wanting to do it day
after day and is that how you keep the
perspective it's not like well it has to
be this end goal is it just sort of a
process you know yeah you have to you
have to enjoy the process right I mean
that's the thing about being an actor I
mean it's your it's your face with so
much rejection and it happens you know
but you just sort of have to enjoy doing
and doing it you know so it's the same
with filmmaking I think I I just if
there's just so many pieces to it and
you just got to keep going until the
film is made you know and so you just
sort of you know just enjoy it but
you're also you do have an end goal you
know you do even when you're making a
movie you're hoping that you're making
the right decisions every time and
you're hoping you're you're you know I'm
probably more neurotic and I come off I
swept everything I really do you know
but that's just part of what makes me
want to care about making sure my actors
are taken care of and and and able to do
what they need to do and
the rest of my crew and their and
everybody that I've had to you know
collaborate with so um so I I can really
be a bundle of nerves oh ok I hat but
you can't say yeah I Aryan cut you know
but on the other hand you know I just
you know I do want have any children
actually does give me a tremendous
amount of perspective I have one but I
mean I I yeah you know I mean it's just
like ultimately at the end of the day
what we're all just we're all just
moving along and doing our thing and
trying to express ourselves and trying
to enjoy that we are working and then
you know but ultimately you know we're
gonna go be mom yet and take care of my
children and take care of our family and
so you really do get some perspective
that way interesting and and I'm sure
the same for you Nicole because just
it's like you at the end of the day it's
still the same you're coming back to the
children and can't maybe get too worked
up over yeah I mean you know they
obviously make everything worth it um
but I mean I guess I mean it's true like
just really getting to appreciate the
process is and my dad has taught me that
since I was so young and I didn't really
understand when he was teaching me for
so long mm-hmm like it's not about the
test it's about that you learned who
cares if we do on the test is if you
really know what I'd be like what do you
mean I go um but it's true I mean I
almost 15 years in LA I still get
excited when they see the Hollywood sign
I mean I live near it but like when I
Drive vitamin oh my god like I am in
Hollywood like I'm going to an audition
in Hollywood like that is my mind
blowing still to me i have i still like
get excited about the little things um
and I think you know there's times where
you I mean everyone goes like gets up
sometime than it's a it's not like every
day I'm like no it's just the little
things that like make it like you know
you just like keep going and make it
exciting and it's it's nice to try to
like kind of capture that and like keep
it in here especially the days where
you're you know you have seven auditions
and for you know like all your cars full
of clothes and and you waited for two
hours and they only had to do scene 1
and then
I'm prepared for scenes are you talking
about it you know but those days that's
really a great like just reminder to be
like you are here like doing what you've
always wanted to do like that is the
most important thing like that is so
awesome and I get so excited about that
and then you get these things like this
movie where we got to go to festivals
and like win awards and stuff that you
don't even dream about like you know and
getting to tell a story like this and
then you have to just you get to use
those as like a little reminder on those
days yeah I wanted to ask about sound
because so many independent films they
do like one sort of setup but it's
usually indoors so how was it because
you the park bench was actually in LA
right yes and Griffith Park ok nice so
how was that because there's police hell
on ebay is just we were just talking
about that previous it was hard it's
challenging um yeah planes go by all the
time and I would stop we would stop I
mean I my sound guy and I had you know a
decision that it's not worth going
through a take that's ruined by by plane
noise so there was a lot of stop downs
and it's a testament to Walter Nicole
because they could they are just such
pros man its true like that they were
first of all flexible you know they just
came in ready knowing of course knowing
the elements and what that part is but
then they could just they stop it's a
drag it's a drag to have to stop halfway
through see and you know but then pick
up again and do it again but we did we
were very vigilant about it we didn't
catch it every time but there's a lot
you know the other thing about sound is
um birds like there's like a lot of
birds on my soundtrack that I had to you
know really work with like it working
outdoors is is a challenge has its
challenges you know in the morning this
sort of these sort of really chirpy
chirpy birds like that's something I
didn't know I wasn't expecting you know
I didn't know learn about nature yes
sure
I had to you know address once i got
into post that's interesting come a
birder everything that exactly so were
you using laughs Mike's I'm sure not as
we did both oh we did laughs and a boom
for everything almost everything unless
it was really really put wide pull out
but yeah we use both and um you know my
my dialogue editor can tell you more
about what we ended up with but I think
for the most part we we used the reuse
the lives because if we were able to get
it clean like because there wasn't too
much rustling of the clothes that was
the way to go because the boom picked up
all this nature ambient sound you know
made it really extra birds I mean you
guys must I don't know that's not my
specialty but compared to other projects
we had to do such little ADR on there
yeah it was mostly everything was
authentic I mean well sometimes you do a
smaller budget movie or something and
you literally feel like you go into a dr
and do the whole movie again yeah we
didn't have to do anything yeah I mean I
really wanted to avoid that right I mean
it's like lesson 1 and feels good you
know to pay attention to your sound and
it's so true i can't i can't stress it
enough it's really really true nothing
separates a real pro film i think from
not is if the sound just doesn't isn't
working right and so you're battling the
the planes are probably you know maybe
police helicopters yeah and then you're
only on the park bench for how many
hours a day cuz you didn't want to lose
that beautiful light that you had yeah
we would start at sunup and we tended
sundown okay so yeah how was that
stopping and starting and finding that
because there were some very emotion
filled scenes that I'm sure then you had
to be like oops sorry holding the plane
well we did we really did work hard I
will say to finish the scene by the by
the end of a shooting day oh my rant we
never had to go back and go back to a
scene that we had started shooting a day
before only like one time but it was the
other perspective like yeah very lucky
today yeah um that way but still they
you know you go ahead sorry no
a lot of times like other you know
there's everyone's trying to do their
job on a set especially set like this
where it's very challenging and Gareth
the cinematographer was so wonderful and
peaceful and calm and she was and it
made a huge difference because when
you're an actor and everyone you know
and then it's like cut you know when
people were mad whatever and like you're
the pool they never they were so careful
and so in tune with what me and Walter
we're doing and what's where we were in
the story whatever that we never got
they were so good about not as much as
they could not pulling us out of the
story for for technical reasons which
was really important for this story
because we didn't we really everything
kind of happened in front of the camera
we've never got to really rehearse
before hand we did all our kind of prep
on our own and it really did kind of
come to life on camera and they were
really aware of that and and we didn't
have a lot of coverage you know I mean
really we just didn't have the luxury of
the time to do a ton of coverage for
every scene so so that you know they
really just had to happen sort of so
keeping with the theme again of the
literary references any books or stories
that sum up your careers as you can
share well I don't think mine thumbs up
my career I mean not yet at least sure
the process yeah i mean i have to say i
think i already said this the the
alchemist is really like that's what I
always kind of go back to is is like
knowing that you know that it's it's
really about about the journey and I
think if you want to be in any kind of
artist that has to be what it's about
and you have to keep bringing yourself
back to that because if not then it's
just heartbreaking and you have and you
know it's really is about the little
things in the journey because if you
know I mean I guess that's what really
what life is about to I mean but I mean
I have to say that book is really a man
I think I've read it approximately 12
times s fine wow that's a good answer
yeah no yeah I'm totally black
take a one yeah I like fiction I don't
know I can't think of anything fiction
as long as you don't see anything wrong
haha Ethan Frome is neither of us really
hard for a change III don't know if I
were a character of a book i would say i
was i would have been a character in an
entire book cuz i love her characters i
think they seem very real to me and but
funny also so golly i I'm completely I
don't have a thing I mean if it was
nonfiction I would have I mean like I
would have to say like I do love Tina
Fey's bossy pants I have read that a
couple times yeah it's funny and it's
true and it's just and it's real and
it's a good kind of piece of kind of
every artists life and I really I have
to say I really like enjoyed it it kind
of makes you just laugh at yourself a
little bit no I think that's great I've
read a lot of biographies you know like
Carol Burnett yeah you know fantastic
yeah um Teri Garr fantastic you know so
in turn you know interesting really
interesting them live that's a that's a
good question you lastly what do you
want people to take away from the park
bench is it about people from two
different worlds seeing that they had
more in common than you know you would
think first meets the eye what is it
because I know it's a very personal
story there's parts of you and it sounds
like there's parts of your mom yeah um
what um well I think it is about two
people who are not like you know they
are they don't come from you know right
opposite ends of the world but there are
just two people who sort of didn't think
they were you know really gonna get
along you know who you know who just
little by little you know there's their
feelings change and I think it's also
ultimately i guess about being open to
to change right and to to sort of
allowing yourself to to to open up to
the possibility
of that you could go a different
direction and and what what does that
mean you know so I think that's part of
it what does it represent to you Wow for
me I think it's it's really the whole I
mean the whole experience what I like
some it come down to it it's really
about kind of just being like true to
what's in your heart which sounds so
generic but it takes a lot of time and
energy to really know what's in your
heart I mean I think people think that
they tour just you know I think you know
you're born and you just know what you
want to do whatever but it takes time to
get to know yourself and so much of this
movie is about they really while they're
telling each other about their stories
and their memories their lives they're
really like getting to know themselves
and I think that a lot of time you think
that like you know yourself or you know
what you what you believe and you know
what you stand for and you you guys you
know and a lot of conversations have
whatever but then sometimes you're
listening yourself talk or like you're
whatever and you're listening to someone
else's story and I you sometimes you
learn more about yourself from something
someone else said and I think and
brought that to life in a way that I've
never seen before and I got to
experience it by getting to to be Emily
and that was that was really really neat
and I think it's carried through to the
more since the movie about the way I
love to listen to people they'll cut the
way that I have conversations now so I
think it's I think it's a really a
really beautiful story that you can kind
of bring into your everyday life